Film Courage: What were some of the biggest
mistakes you made early on in your filmmaking
career?
Zeke Zelker, Writer/Director/Producer of the
transmedia project BILLBOARD: Rushing.
Early on I would rush through scripts, rush
into production, rush through post so I could
share it.
That is probably my biggest problem for instance
I had this problem A.K.A.: It's a Wiley World!
And then I rush into production because my
Dad always wanted to be in a movie and he
was dying of cancer.
I literally would wear my heart on my sleeve
with a lot of things that I do and the reasons
why I do certain things but that was probably
my biggest lesson learned and so now I take
my time.
I believe in story R&D [research and development]
where I like to make things or break things,
test things in front of audiences and see
what’s working or not working.
For instance with BILLBOARD we have a web
series part of this where we tested it in
front of a live audience as a play.
I never staged a play before in my life but
I just did it.
It was successful, it’s crazy.
It was an interactive play where the audience
interacted with the characters via social
media.
On one screen above the billboards was information
that the billboard sitters were putting out,
on another screen was what the audiences were
putting in some of the action on the stage
was improv based on that correspondence.
I mean the actors weren’t literally Tweeting
and stuff.
We had a whole other team doing that kind
of stuff but it was just very interesting
and very dynamic and it was an experiment.
But it was interesting what we learned from
it was how the audience was reacting to the
material that would then become the web series.
You know you think about it, filmmaking should
really take more of a thought about what TV
does in terms of “Filmed before a live studio
audience.”
Right?
So just what TV does, what do they do?
They rehearse it for the first two days, bring
it to a live audience, they tape it four times.
They change some stuff up if something is
not hitting right and they finally do the
taping (the end taping, the last two tapings
I should say).
And I think filmmaking should take a little
bit of that.
Like for instance with BILLBOARD we did sneak
previews this past fall to test our audience
because we thought we knew who our audience
was based off of earlier test screenings and
also doing AB testing with Facebook ads and
so forth but we wanted to make sure that that
was it and making sure that they responded
to the material and so we did a bunch of sneak
previews to test how the audience was reacting
to the material and making sure that our test
audience was the actual audience.
And in fact I actually ended up shooting two
scenes that end up in the final film.
So I firmly believe in story R&D.
And so now the lesson learned was not rush
but take your time.
Also too not having all of the resources at
your disposal also warrants taking your time
as well.
The other lesson I learned too was a matter
of empowering people to be successful.
Teach them all that you can and hand the objective
over to them and make sure they hit their
tasks.
And I still have the same sort of organizational
stuff that I had for my very first film.
You have to realize that I learn by doing.
I didn’t learn this stuff in school because
I had one semester of film school behind me
so I literally learned by doing.
So over the course of the years I think I
became a better and better filmmaker and I’ve
lost my arrogance.
I don’t think filmmakers should be arrogant.
I think they should really listen to their
audience and figure out who they are actually
appealing to.